merci d'être avec nous dans le vieux et
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous représenter les Français
établis hors de France membre du groupe
les républicains vous présidez ici au
Sénat le groupe d'amitié France
Allemagne on va bien sûr parler des
relations entre les deux pays dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est évidemment
cette présentation au Conseil des
Ministres de la réforme des retraites
face à la mobilisation d'ampleur je dis
dernier est-ce que le gouvernement doit
revoir sa copie
déjà il y a une bonne nouvelle c'est que
très clairement l'espérance de vie
augmente on le voit les chiffres nous le
donne en 1981 l'espérance de vie pour
une femme était de 78 ans et demi
aujourd'hui il est de 85 ans et demi en
1981 pour un homme c'était un peu plus
de 70 ans aujourd'hui c'est 79 ans donc
très clairement l'espérance de vie
augmente et ça a une conséquence
notamment sur notre démographie et le
fait que nous avions en 1964 cotisants
pour un actif aujourd'hui on est à 1,7
et le conseil d'orientation de retraite
nous montre clairement que dans les
années à venir ce ratio en réalité va
encore baisser donc on a une situation
qui est une situation de déficit
structurel
toujours le corps nous explique de 2024
à 2034 on s'attend à 13 à 15 milliards
de déficits par an donc sur 10 ans ça
nous fait 150 milliards d'euros de
déficit donc
une très bonne nouvelle de départ c'est
que l'espérance de vie augmente en bonne
santé là encore ça augmente et que on se
retrouve avec un système de retraite qui
tout simplement devient structurellement
déficitaire donc il faut bien qu'il y
ait une réforme des retraites il y a
plusieurs options pour le financer et la
bonne est-ce que de ce qu'on connaît de
ce texte qui ne sera pas qui sera pas
modifié a priori en conseil des
ministres des modifications au Parlement
mais on connaît quand même les grandes
lignes du texte est-ce que vous le
voterez en l'état alors déjà on vote un
texte final c'est à dire amender
notamment avec les amendements du Sénat
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a des
modifications à porter bien sûr bien sûr
alors la révélation des petites
retraites à taux plein ça c'est une
exigence notamment qui a été exprimée
par
erikiotti Bruno Retailleau Olivier
marlex et c'est une exigence absolue sur
la propagation des petites retraites et
ça ce sera dans le texte un logo
gouvernement la confirmière voilà donc
effectivement donc de toute façon nous
le texte qui arrivera au Sénat on verra
quel sera le texte qui sera devant le
Sénat mais et puis il y aura également
des des amendements possibles je pense
notamment dans les priorités à la prise
en compte de la durée de cotisation pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler très
jeune
qui pourrait être amené à faire 44 ans
de cotisations ça pour vous c'est non
écoutez comme je vous dis ça dépend du
texte final mais les points de vigilance
c'est ça les petites retraites les
carrières commencaient très jeunes il y
a évidemment l'intégration des congés
parentaux je pense notamment
par exemple au retraites des femmes et
puis l'amélioration de l'emploi des
seniors donc ça c'est les points de
vigilance après on ne vote que le texte
final donc évidemment c'est ça qu'il
faudra analyser
on va passer à l'actualité d'hier
actualité franco-allemande puisque
Emmanuel Macron et le chancelier
allemand Olaf Scholl ce sont retrouvés à
Paris pour célébrer les 60 ans du traité
de l'Elysée traité de l'amitié
franco-allemand qui définit le cadre de
la coopération entre l'Allemagne et la
France on va faire le point sur cette
journée avec notre journaliste Alexa
[Musique]
[Rires]
les 60 ans de la réconciliation entre
les deux pays avec la volonté d'afficher
l'unité du groupe franco-allemand il
faut dire Alex que cette unité c'était
un peu perdu ces derniers mois oui on le
rappelle depuis que est arrivé au
pouvoir en Allemagne elle est relations
se sont refroidies avec la France en
témoigne et l'annulation de de conseils
des ministres franco-allemand à cause de
divergences sur des sujets stratégiques
entre les deux pays sur le prix du gaz
que l'Allemagne refuse de plafonner sur
la réponse à apporter aux
protectionnisme américain la France veut
une réponse forte pas l'Allemagne alors
cela fait partie de la vie d'un couple
franco-allemand a expliqué hier oh la
scholls à la Sorbonne alors qu'il
faisait un discours avec Emmanuel Macron
devant les parlementaires des deux pays
le moteur franco-allemand est une
machine de compromis une machine bien
graissée mais qui parfois peut être
bruitante et témoigne d'un travail ardu
il ne marche pas à coup de flatterie et
de symbolique vide de sens et
du côté d'Emmanuel Macron il faut bien
réveiller ce couple franco-allemand et
plus globalement il faut réveiller
l'Europe avec un projet de refondation à
bâtir notamment autour de l'énergie
puisque la guerre en Ukraine a révélé
les fragilités énergétiques de l'Europe
on va écouter le président de la
République
Allemagne et la France parce qu'elles
ont défricher le chemin de la
réconciliation doivent devenir pionnière
pour la refondation de notre Europe
ensemble
pionnière d'abord pour bâtir ensemble un
nouveau modèle énergétique par de là nos
différences
nous devons encourager et accélérer au
niveau européen les investissements
publics et privés nécessaires à la
transition écologique alors au terme de
cette journée Paris et Berlin ont assuré
cette remise d'accord sur je cite une
réponse rapide et ambitieuse aux
investissements industriels massifs que
les États-Unis font sur leur sol en
revanche pas d'accord toujours sur le
projet de bouclier antimissiles
européens l'Allemagne préférant et bien
des technologies américaines et
israélienne enfin on peut dire qu'un
billet de train franco-allemand à
destination des jeunes des deux pays va
être lancée notamment pour favoriser les
échanges des deux côtés du rein Ronan Le
Bleu malgré ses très belles célébration
de l'amitié franco-allemande qui dure
depuis 60 ans et ce qu'on peut dire
quand même que ce couple est un ce
moteur comme dirait la scholls est un
peu en panne
bon déjà c'est cérémonies elles sont
nécessaires importantes pour réaffirmer
ce traité de l'Elysée qui a été voulu
par le général de Gaulle chancelier
Conrad Adenauer et qui s'élait
véritablement la réconciliation donc
c'est absolument indispensable que ce
type de cérémonie a eu lieu et
d'ailleurs j'accompagnais hier le
président Gérard Larcher qui recevait
son homologue Peter tientcher le
président du Bundes strat pour justement
réaffirmer cette volonté toujours plus
forte de travailler main dans la main
alors concrètement effectivement vous le
dites les Français parlent de coupe
franco-allemand les allemands parlent de
moteur franco-allemand dans un pays
industriel passionné d'automobile le
moteur c'est évidemment une valeur forte
et en fait ce que l'on constate c'est
qu'il y a un décrochage économique de la
France par rapport à l'Allemagne qui a
des conséquences multiples
très clairement aujourd'hui il y a 1000
milliards d'écarts de PIB entre la
France et l'Allemagne tous les ans
ça c'est une réalité économique
fondamentale c'est que l'Allemagne est
devenue l'hyperpuissance économique en
Europe se décrochage il est notamment dû
à la désindustrialisation de la France
au fait que nous n'avons pas fait de
réforme du marché du travail que avec
les 35 heures nous avons eu des pertes
de compétitivité et donc au même moment
l'Allemagne faisait des réformes de son
marché du travail qui était beaucoup
plus ambitieuse et notamment une réforme
des retraites et donc se décrochage n'a
fait que s'accentuer dans le temps
surtout à partir de 2010 où tous les
mois il y avait une croissance du PIB
allemand qui était supérieure à celui de
la France aujourd'hui on a ce décrochage
de 1000 milliards d'écarts de PIB et par
ailleurs avec la réunification le 3
octobre 1990 l’allemagne a un peu changé
son centre de gravité la capitale
passant de bonnes à Berlin c'est à dire
vrai traitement de l'Europe occidentale
et s'est rapproché de l'Europe centrale
et avec l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne elle recourt aujourd'hui une
position totalement centrale en Europe
et la difficulté à laquelle fait face le
coupe franco-allemand c'est cette
différence qui qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de pays européens se tournent
vers l'Allemagne et l'Allemagne a une
tendance à faire en sorte que ce coupe
franco-allemand ne se parle plus
strictement des gala égal c'est un
danger pour l'Union européenne d'avoir
cette situation donc il faut que la
France rattrape son retard économique
par rapport à l'Allemagne pour que se
décrochage ne sont que économique fait
que l'Allemagne se sent supérieur à la
France c'est ça dans l'état d'esprit
allemand c'est ça les habitants en
Allemagne exactement donc d'un point de
vue économique c'est très clair mais la
France a d'autres attributs de puissance
la France surtout depuis le brexit et le
seul pays de l'Union européenne a
disposé à la fois d'un siège permanent
au Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
et à disposer de la dissuasion nucléaire
nous étions deux dans l'Union européenne
depuis le brexit nous sommes le seul
pays à disposer de ces attributs de
puissance
la France dispose de la première armée
d'Europe c'est un contesté et donc très
clairement ce qu'il y a dans ce couple
franco-allemand c'est que chacun a ses
forces et ses faiblesses mais il ne faut
pas qu'il y ait se décrochage se
décrochage notamment économique il est
important il faut être extrêmement
vigilant sur ce point dans l'équilibre
des puissances en Europe mais face au
défi qui sont posés à l'Europe notamment
industriel énergétique écologique on a
l'impression qu'Emmanuel Macron il
privilégie des solutions européennes
communes quand parfois l'Allemagne joue
une carte plus personnelle peut-être du
fait de sa puissance économique
chaque État dans l'Union européenne
défend ses propres intérêts
et
je crois que là-dessus on peut pas en
vouloir un pays ou à un autre de vouloir
défendre ses intérêts maintenant c'est
une maison commune l'Union européenne il
faut évidemment travailler ensemble mais
en fait on a une autre difficulté dans
ce couple franco-allemand c'est
l'éloignement du 8 mai 1945
les générations au pouvoir ne sont pas
les générations qui ont connu mais même
pas leurs parents et donc en réalité ce
qui est le fondement de ce cette
réconciliation c'est bien la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui s'éloigne dans le
temps et donc aujourd'hui évidemment ce
n'est plus uniquement la paix qui est le
moteur de la construction donc ça c'est
un autre facteur et puis il y a un
troisième facteur c'est clairement le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
qui entraîne en Allemagne la volonté
nécessaire notamment d'investir dans les
enjeux de défense avec le fond de 100
milliards d'euros et surtout le passage
à 2% de PI pour les enjeux de défense
c'est-à-dire plus de 70 milliards par an
sur les budgets de défense et tout ça
entraîne une un déséquilibre dans la
relation entre nos deux pays il faut
être très vigilant sur ce point l'Europe
c'est l'équilibre des puissances mais
moi justement sur la défense puisque
l'Allemagne a décidé de se rémer en
augmenter considérablement son budget de
défense il faut s'en inquiéter alors
souvenons-nous notamment des
déclarations de Donald Trump quand il
était président des États-Unis et qui
rappelait à l'Allemagne qu'il faut
investir 2% de PIB sur les budgets de
défense quand on est membre de l'OTAN et
donc il y avait une pression finalement
américaine notamment sur l'Allemagne
pour qu'elle augmente son budget de
défense à l'époque elle était 1,3% de
PIB bon donc de toute façon le continent
européen aujourd'hui doit faire un
effort de défense commun la guerre est
aux frontières de l'Union européenne et
donc c'est une nécessité pour tous il
faut que tous les pays de l'Union
européenne prennent conscience et on
voit que cette prise de conscience est
en train de réaliser donc ça c'est pas
une mauvaise nouvelle mais on il y a une
nécessité d'investissement dans les
enjeux de défense qui est très clair
aujourd'hui donc
par contre il faut toujours être
vigilant sur la relation
franco-allemande sur les programmes
communs le système de combat aérien du
futur France Allemagne Espagne le mgcs
c'est-à-dire le char du futur donc il
faut qu'on avance sur ces projets qui
sont nécessaires on va en parler le
temps de remercier Alex merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on parlera du Parti
socialiste ça se déchire on verra ça
tout à l'heure on verra ça dans le club
merci Alex on va continuer à parler de
ces questions défenses et de cette
journée puisqu'il y a relève Scholl
c'est Emmanuel Macron était d'accord
pour dire qu'il fallait soutenir
l'Ukraine tant qu'elle en avait besoin
mais concrètement est-ce que le soutien
qu'apporte la France et l'Allemagne à
l'Ukraine est suffisant est-ce qu'il est
opérationnel alors la France a livré 18
canons César dont les militaires
Ukrainiens sont très satisfaits si Canon
TFR 1 de lance-roquette mx-10rc des
véhicules blindés VAP de transport de
troupes des systèmes crotale de défense
anti-aériennes donc l'effort de la
France pour soutenir l'Ukraine est réel
évidemment c'est tout à fait
compréhensible que l'Ukraine demande des
efforts toujours supplémentaires mais il
faut aussi tenir compte de ce que la
France a déjà fait comme comme effort
donc
ce qui se pose concrètement c'est la
question des chats parce que on voit que
les Russes sont en train de grignoter du
terrain ils disent avancer dans la
région de zapporica est-ce qu'il faut
livrer des chars lourds à l'Ukraine pour
aider les Ukrainiens enfin face à cette
avancée russe
alors il faut tenir compte déjà de nos
propres capacités est-ce que la France a
vraiment les moyens de livrer les chats
sur le principe de livrer des chartes
Leclerc personnellement j'y suis pas
défavorable mais c'est il faut d'abord
faire une analyse très précise des
besoins de la France parce que il
faudrait pas
désarmer la France pour armer l'Ukraine
donc ça c'est un point fondamental
ensuite en Allemagne le débat fait rage
sur la question des léopards 2
l'Allemagne il souveraine pour le
décider c'est pas la France de le dire
par contre c'est vrai que si la France
devait un jour prendre la décision que
des chars lourds puissent être livrés
des chars français puisse être livré à
l'Ukraine cela pourrait peut-être avoir
une influence sur le débat public en
Allemagne pour enclencher si vous voulez
cette prise de décision en Allemagne
donc en tout cas le débat fait rage en
Allemagne je crois qu'il est pas
tranchée
Leclerc ça mettrait la pression sur
l'Allemagne si la France devait le faire
je pense Macron dit rien n'était exclu
mais vous comprenez ce flou qui est
entretenu sur cette question oui ben
écoutez en tout cas ce qui est très
clair c'est que pour l'Allemagne c'est
un changement de doctrine extrêmement
important l'idée que l'Ukraine ne soit
ni membre de l'Union européenne ni de
l'OTAN et de livrer des armes à un pays
qui est voilà qui n'est pas dans c'est
une nouveauté et
cela va un peu à l'encontre de la
tradition pour qui l'armée allemande est
totalement intégrée à la fois dans
l'OTAN dans l'Union européenne et dans
les missions internationales de l'ONU
donc c'est une c'est un changement de
doctrine et donc il faut comprendre d'où
l'on vient pour savoir au quelle est la
situation d'aujourd'hui le flou il est
aussi du côté allemand parce qu'il y a
Olaf Scholl c'est resté assez flou hein
lui aussi sur la livraison de sécher et
puis hier soir il y a cinq ministre des
Affaires étrangères allemandes qui est
invité sur LCI et alors elle elle a été
beaucoup plus claire elle dit que Berlin
ne s'opposera pas la livraison de
charleopards de la part de la Pologne
c'est la question lui est posée ça vous
a surpris cette déclaration qu'est-ce
qu'il faut comprendre de ce qui se joue
en Allemagne non seulement pas surpris
parce que la coalition gouvernementale
en Allemagne est faite de trois partis
politiques distincts les sociodémocrates
du SPD de la scholls Analena berbock la
ministre des Affaires étrangères qui
s'est exprimée hier et des vers et puis
il y a une troisième partenaire le FDP
qui sont les libéraux et chacun de ces
trois parties qui forment la coalition
en Allemagne ont des positions tranchées
en réalité on voit bien que les Verts
poussent pour la livraison de ces chars
léopards 2 et que Olaf Scholl c'est
beaucoup plus hésitant pour vous on
n'est pas dans un tournant on est plus
dans une question de politique interne
on n'est pas dans un tournant de la
doctrine allemande voilà c'est ce sont
des discussions internes entre les
différents partis qui forment la
coalition en Allemagne ils ne sont pas
sur les mêmes positions et donc en fait
on voit bien que un Alena berboch essaye
de faire changer son partenaire
principal qui est le les sociaux qui
sont les sociaux-démocrates du SPD à
travers Olivet on va continuer à parler
de question on va retrouver Jefferson
des sports bonjour Jefferson merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste
politique à sud-ouest et spécialiste des
questions de défense et de Jefferson
vous étiez vendredi à Mont-de-Marsan à
l'occasion des vœux d'Emmanuel Macron
aux forces armées le président qui a
annoncé une enveloppe de 413 milliards
d'euros pour les armées dans le cadre de
la future loi de programmation militaire
c'est un tiers de plus que le budget de
la précédente loi de programmation
militaire qu'est-ce que ça signifie de
faire ça
oui Oriane cette loi de programmation
militaire c'est une photo d'une course
au ramement mondiale aurait un moment
tout azimut des États-Unis à la Chine en
passant par la Russie bien sûr mais on
pourrait citer l'Inde l'Australie
l'Allemagne vous en avez parlé donc la
France qui n'entend pas rester hacker
pour faire simple cette loi de
programmation militaire c'est la
traduction d'un monde toujours plus
dangereux et surtout qui intègre le
retour de la guerre en Europe avec cette
guerre en Ukraine face à l'envahisseur
russe avant vendredi avant-de-marsan
Emmanuel Macron l'a dit il ne faut pas
avoir une guerre de retard mais bien une
guerre d'avance c'est à dire si les
enjeux sont considérables et cette
augmentation conséquente et cet effort
inédit pour le budget des armées devra y
contribuer
précisément Jefferson à quoi va servir
cet effort
alors très concrètement ça va cette
manne financière va devoir irriguer tous
les secteurs toutes les composantes des
forces françaises mais on va retenir
trois exemples très significatifs le
premier c'est la dissuasion nucléaire
qui va continuer d'être modernisé et
améliorer c'est bien là le cœur de la
souveraineté française et de la
particularité française parce que seul 9
pays ont la bombe atomique on est dans
un club donc très fermé depuis 1964 la
France a cet arsenal nucléaire et depuis
plus de 20 000 jours d'alerte non-stop
se sont succédés il n'y a pas
d'interruption dans la dissuasion
nucléaire donc là c'est vraiment la clé
de voûte qui va être renforcée deux
autres exemples le deuxième c'est la
défense solaire là les capacités
françaises vont être augmentées d'au
moins 50% et c'est un enseignement
direct de la guerre en Ukraine parce que
c'est ce qui permet la défense solaire
c'est ce qui permet aux Ukrainiens de
résister aux frappes russes et notamment
à l'aviation à long rayon d'action de la
Russie qui frappe l'Ukraine et le
troisième point Oriane c'est
le virage des drones ce virage n'a pas
été pris au début des années 2000 par
les armées françaises il y a un manque
ici à réparer et cette LPM va devoir
faire entrer l'armée française dans
l'ère des drones je pourrais aussi te
aussi citer la marine avec un objectif
très ambitieux qui est fixé c'est la
maîtrise des fonds marins jusqu'à 6000
mètres de profondeur après les drones
aériens on va voir arriver les drones
sous-marins vous avez vous souvenez des
explosions sur les gaz au ducs
dernièrement voilà il y a des enjeux
aussi pour la marine donc concrètement
voilà toutes les composantes devront en
bénéficier des personnes vous avez deux
questions pour le sénateur je vous
laisse poser la première
oui le sénateur monsieur sénateur vous
connaissez parfaitement les enjeux de
défense on en a déjà parlé mais
simplement est-ce que cette LPM ça va
dans le bon sens vous le disiez il y a
des enjeux de défense et des nécessités
de réinvestissement partout oui cette
LPM va dans le bon sens on a 100
milliards d'euros de plus que dans la
loi de programmation militaire
précédente ça fait passer le budget de
nos armées à si on prend 413 milliards
sur 7 ans ça fait 59 milliards par an
aujourd'hui on est à 44 milliards donc
très clairement il y a une montée en
puissance et c'est une nécessité
évidente la guerre est aux portes de
l'Union européenne la guerre est sur le
continent européen
dans les nécessités il y a le passage au
sein de l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
autour rafale
pour l'armée de terre évidemment c'est
le programme scorpion de rénovation des
blindés de l'armée de terre évidemment
vous l'avez dit très justement les
drones mais il y a aussi le quantique
l'intelligence artificielle le cyber et
puis il faut des investissements bien
plus importants en termes de
renseignement aussi bien au niveau de la
DRM que de la drsd donc vous voyez il y
a beaucoup de champs
la DRM c'est le renseignement militaire
en opération extérieure en OPEX et la
drsd c'est plutôt la contre-ingérence
économique et cyber donc très clairement
il y a des nécessités d'investissement
massif sur les enjeux de défense nous en
avons rappelé quelques-uns et donc il y
a besoin de cette montée en puissance de
cette nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire donc oui ça va dans le bon
sens des personnes une autre question et
oui une dernière question je veux pas
revenir sur vous allez s'exprimer sur
les chars Leclerc simplement sur les des
livraisons d'armes françaises à
l'Ukraine est-ce que sur le risque de
déshabiller en tout cas de désarmer la
France est-ce que cette question est
vraiment prégnante après la livraison
des 18 qui annonçaita des rues etc tout
ce que vous avez cité mais en tout cas
est-ce qu'il y a une vigilance pour vous
les sénateurs la commission de défense
sur ce risque de désarmement français
oui bien sûr il faut être extrêmement
vigilant sur ce point il faut absolument
conserver
nos outils de défense du territoire
national et donc effectivement toutes
ces décisions de soutien à l'Ukraine ne
peuvent se faire qu'au regard de nos
propres capacités il n'est pas question
d'affaiblir évidemment notre armée il
faut la renforcer bien au contraire
jusque là cette ligne rouge n'a pas n'a
pas été franchie pas encore justement
c'est un point de vigilance constant
mais on n'est pas dans cette situation à
ce stade effectivement
de Sud-Ouest c'est la réforme des
retraites elle a une de Sud-Ouest
aujourd'hui les réponses à vos questions
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Jefferson d'avoir été avec nous
depuis Bordeaux on va terminer en
parlant de votre partie des républicains
rendant le bleu puisque ça y est on
connaît l'organigramme des républicains
depuis la prise de fonction d'érections
cette organigramme chargé des Français
de l'étranger Bruno Retailleau qui était
le l'adversaire d'Éric Ciotti au second
tour dénonce un déséquilibre est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord bon déjà il faut
rappeler que le scrutin s'est passé sans
aucune contestation il n'y a pas eu de
de commission
c'est votre interprétation bon écoutez
donc il y a pas donc le le scrutin n'a
absolument pas été contesté dans la vie
d'un parti politique évidemment ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui ça arrive dans la
vie de beaucoup de partis politiques je
crois que
Éric ce type Bruno Retailleau vont se
voir et tout ça va va s'apaiser
évidemment le seul objectif c'est le
rassemblement et l'unité et je crois que
c'est pas d'inquiétude là dessus vous
n'avez pas d'inquiétude sur les
divisions qui pourraient avoir lieu dans
votre partie est-ce que c'est opportun
d'afficher ces divisions qui concernent
un organigramme interne non mais écoutez
ça c'est la vie classique d'une famille
politique et en réalité ce qui va vous
allez voir l'unité le rassemblement sera
au rendez-vous je suis pas inquiet sur
ce point il va pouvoir le faire le
rassemblement Éric chattier avec des
lignes qui sont différentes on le voit
déjà sur la réforme des retraites il y a
une partie des députés qui disent mais
nous on doit te rappeler le texte en
état alors qu'Eric Ciotti dit le
contraire ça va être compliqué pour lui
de faire rassemblement
écouter sur la réforme des retraites
aussi bien donc le président du parti
eriksiotique le président donc du groupe
les républicains au Sénat Bruno
Retailleau et à l'Assemblée nationale
Olivier Marleix ont tous les trois pris
une position en expliquant que une
réforme était nécessaire mais qu'elle
devait être juste donc il y a pas de
différence entre Aurélien Pradier pour
vous non mais alors là c'est évidemment
Aurélien Pradier effectivement fait
valoir un certain nombre de nécessités
mais c'est aussi le travail
parlementaire d'amendement d'un d'un
projet de loi donc il y a pas de il y a
pas d'inquiétude sur ce point merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
c'est avec nous dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on parlera
justement de cette réforme des retraites
puisque vous le savez c'est aujourd'hui
que le texte est présenté on conseille
des ministres mais d'abord on va
continuer en parler avec notre prochaine
invité c'est Alexis Corbière qui vous
succède merci roman le globe